[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you've been that to
me every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without it
[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalist welcome to episode
number 80 today we're going to talk
about family Sean you got any music for
us you can you can insert here
oh that is my jam haha
that is a jam okay
the jam I have heard before yes yes
indeed well we are going to talk about
family today but first Ryan I'd like to
know how you have time for anything when
you're so busy just keeping it real what
we are back in back in Montana for a
short period of time we we've been in
the middle of this less is now tour
we're twelve cities into a forty city
tour if you want to come out and see us
it's just less is now calm but Josh when
are we gonna go to England Josh what are
we gonna go to Berlin listen now calm
what if we go to Brazil less than now
back home and before we dive in here I
just want to say thanks real quick we
have about five hundred patreon
supporters in a month now and Ryan and I
as well as podcast Sean we're trying to
build a new podcast recording studio and
also we're trying to hire a full-time
filmmaker so we can do a video version
of the podcast also do a bunch of other
meaningful video creations live streams
interviews all kinds of stuff we're
trying to do and if you want to support
us none of the money goes to me Orion
personally but allows us to pay the
folks that we need to pay also build the
studio we need to build we'd really
appreciate your support because we
refuse to clutter this podcast with
advertisements just head on over to
patreon comm slash the minimalists you
can also find that in the show notes or
to set over to the minimalists comm and
click on that donate button at the top
you can contribute just once via PayPal
or you can do per episode over at
patreon and that support really helps us
sustain this podcast and create some
meaningful stuff thanks for being a part
of that Jill all right Ryan well you say
we
right in Yemen beautiful our first first
question is from Emily in Ottawa I'm
wondering if you have any thoughts on
how caring for others fits into
minimalism I'm a mom of two boys ages
six and four I have a loving husband
have a dad who lives on his own but uses
a power chair a power wheelchair and
needs extra help on a regular basis I
also have a grandmother who is 99 years
young and I am currently power of
attorney for her finances on top of that
I work full time I have daily
responsibilities and chores I try to
make time for friends and family time
for myself by getting enough sleep and
all of that um there are people in my
life that depend on me as a caretaker
and I sometimes struggle to find balance
with all these aspects of my life I'm
sure I'm not the only one I don't think
I'm the only one in a situation like
this and I wonder if you have any tips
or tricks to offer yeah I really like
the first thing that Emily said Ryan she
talked about being a minimalist in
progress and I think you and I are still
in progress right hopeless
don't tell or don't tell our fans they
think we've self actualized will be
ruined you know what I it's what's
really nice about this about this
journey is as your life changes the
things that add value to your life will
change and your circumstances will
change as well now emily has some
interesting circumstances here she she's
dealing with a lot and well you have
several full-time jobs being a mom to
two boys in and of itself can be a
full-time job being a spouse is a
full-time job or a partner to someone as
a full-time job taking care of your
parents or your grandparents can often
be or at least feel like a full-time gig
and of course you have your own full
time job that you have to attend to as
well and what you're struggling with
right now is you have all these people
that depend on you right Emily has these
people who
who are her dependents either like in
the the IRS sense of the word like you
can claim them on your taxes or they're
just people who depend on you and by the
way there are many other people you
didn't list who depend on you there are
co-workers and bosses and customers and
employees and and all these other people
that are at work that depend on you in
some form or fashion and you are trying
to balance all of that with also alone
time and sleep and and trying to be your
own individual and I think that man what
the word that that keeps coming to mind
here as I'm as I'm talking through this
is balance how does how does one stay
balanced when you're constantly
bombarded by other people's demands
whether that's work whether it's the
people in your household or family and
also your own demands the demands that
we put on on ourselves as well and it
reminded me of this really brief essay
that Seth Godin wrote the title of it is
an overlooked secret to effectiveness
and as a parenthesis there and happiness
knowing where enough is so he's
basically saying that's the overlooked
secret knowing where enough is more
might be better for a while but sooner
or later it can always be better
diminishing returns are the law not an
exception if we look to advertisers
marketers bosses doctors partners and
suppliers to tell us when we've reached
enough we're almost certainly going to
get it wrong it's ok to stop when you're
happy is more always better know
sometimes only better is better I think
we need to keep that in mind here Ryan
as she's going through and dealing with
all of these other people her gas tank
might be empty and if you aren't growing
as an individual if you don't have
enough for yourself enough sleep enough
health enough passion enough creativity
enough positive relationships enough
sense of well-being if you don't feel
like your actions are aligned with the
person you want to become then all of a
sudden you feel poor
in a bunch of different directions
you're gonna feel drained and if you
feel drained for too long you feel empty
and I think that's what spurred Emily's
question here is she is she doesn't know
what to cut out at this point because
everything seems so important and when
everything is important then nothing
becomes important and and so I think the
key the key for Emily here is to
identify what is non-essential and for
me minimalism has allowed me to identify
what isn't essential in my life and then
and then conversely take what is
essential and then prioritize those
things because we might have 10
different priorities in our life even
though that's a strange thing because
that word priority used to always just
be singular there was never a a plural
use of that word until the 20th century
we used to say this is my priority
priority just means the first thing if
you have 10 priorities you have 10 the
first things and that the math just
doesn't work right and so instead of
having multiple priorities we need to
figure out what is most important to us
get it down to as few priorities as
possible and thankfully I think Emily
has done that to a great extent and she
said a few things in passing that you
could tell our priorities but there are
things that she wants to view priorities
right now there lip-service priorities
so well I want to make sure I get enough
sleep well are you actually getting
enough sleep are you tracking your sleep
are and and if not then it's going to
bleed over into every other area of of
your life and so what I'd love for you
to do is usual I would ask someone to go
back and take a look at the last 24
hours how did you spend the last day but
with you you've got these different
priorities in your life how did you
spend your last week go look at the last
week and if you can't remember
everything and start today and write
down although it's a little bit harder
because once you know you're measuring
it it actually changes things remember
Ryan when we took our when we added that
that app to our phones called moment all
of a sudden immediately once you start
tracking your behavior your behavior
changes like the observation of the
thing automatically changes the thing
which could be a good thing for Emily so
I'd love you to go back for the last
week write down what you did everyday
and and I mean even though my new show
go how often did you check email how
often did you
you know go to Facebook or go to YouTube
or how often did you watch television
how often did you do these things that
are maybe non-essentials in your life
and then how often did you spend time on
the essential things in your life and
once you've made that list I love to
reckon I would love you to recognize
what you're most busy days were where
did you feel most overwhelmed there's
usually an indicator for me to realize
that wow I was way too busy last
Wednesday because I felt so overwhelmed
and then on those busiest days one of
the things you could have said no to and
it's really important to get clear on
that because we want to say no to the
non-essential things first so that we
can say yes to the things that are
essential and if you have extra time
then you can prioritize some of the
non-essential things in your life as
well some of those things are important
some of those things add value to your
life Entertainment is important to me
but it's not something that is
absolutely essential to my life and so I
have to keep that in mind and then also
you have a lot of people in your life no
one to ask for help that's one thing
that I struggled with for a long time
Ryan and I think I've done a lot better
over the last four or five years for
sure but I used to want to accomplish
everything on my own and I figured out
actually back in the corporate world as
when I really started to figure out as I
ascended the corporate ladder like I
can't do everything myself if you're
managing a bunch of retail stores you
can't help every customer you can't you
can get involved in every employee
dispute even and so you have to delegate
some things and so sometimes when you're
friends and family and people are coming
to you you're going to have to delegate
some things to them and your whether
it's your kids or your spouse or your
parents or grandparents or people at
work you're going to find ways to
effectively delegate to some of the
people in your life and the last thing
I'm going to say real quick is I want
you to use your calendar so this is the
measurement part I want you to schedule
out your days because if you really
prioritize your days you don't want this
nebulous sort of well I think I've got
some work to do this afternoon and I
think I'm going to check email this
evening now I want you to schedule those
things I want you to schedule the
essentials
first and I think I should start with me
time and for you it's in the lead time
what is the the me time and schedule
that in there first you need that alone
time and you probably need even more
alone time if you are if you're an
introvert and so you have to figure that
out as well
schedule that me time in there first
schedule you're sleeping as well that is
so important it will help every other
area of life or it will hurt every other
area of life if you are not sleeping
enough and then from there scheduling
all of your other priorities obviously
you have to go to work right you have to
spend time at work you want to spend
time with your husband and then your
kids and then of course your dad and
your grandma and that will change from
time to time and you'll also want to ask
other people to help out with those
things and then schedule in the
non-essential items your calendar should
be full every day at least for now so
while you develop those habits that you
need to have a more effective I won't
say productive because we mistake
productivity for effectiveness but how
do we have the most effective day
possible and right now for you it's
about scheduling those blocks of time so
you can use your time to the best of
your ability it's so the only resource
we all have the same exact thing if you
don't have the same amount of money as
everyone else you don't have the same
amount of skills you don't have the same
amount of resources but you do have the
same amount of time in a day 24 hours
let's try to spend it wisely Ryan what
do you think for Emily yeah the good
news emily is that you are not alone
everyone has has trouble balancing
balancing their lives when it comes to
working when it comes to providing and
especially in your situation when it
comes for other people who are depending
on you and yeah I would say going back
to the metaphor Josh used with your gas
tank being empty if your gas tank is
empty right now Emily then you can't
even help yourself let alone anyone else
so whatever you have to do if it is
scheduling better sleep if it is
scheduling alone time if it is
scheduling a time for you to go out by
yourself and watch a movie whatever it
may be
yeah I totally agree with Josh that is
exactly where you've got to start we all
know that meta
or of you know the oxygen masks when
they drop from the ceiling on the plane
you got to put yours on first so you can
assist other people because if you don't
do that
well then both people might die if
that's if that's the case so you know
that's that's a little bit of an extreme
example but I think you understand what
I'm saying here is it's not we're not
Josh and I aren't saying to focus on
yourself and only yourself but it does
start with making sure your gas tank is
full so you can help others and I
totally agree about finding out what
your priorities are you know it's funny
with art with our approach to minimalism
Josh we started with the packing party
and getting rid of the excess stuff so
we can figure out what was important to
us right and I would say start with
instead of starting with the things in
art that are non-essential start with
the things that are essential write
those down on a piece of paper because
those are the things that you need to
say yes to those are the things you
absolutely have to say yes soon anything
else that pops into your life this is
where you're going to have to get really
good at saying no you're gonna have to
say no to a lot of things in order to
help these people and be there for the
people that really really really need
you and lastly I would say when it comes
to asking for help maybe your friends or
family I'm assuming that you probably
have a couple people out there who could
assist not you know 20 hours a week but
maybe it's just you know five hours a
week one hour a day for five days a week
whatever it may be I'm assuming you have
someone help you if you don't take an ad
out on Craigslist because you got to ask
yourself a question like if you could
pay someone 15 bucks an hour for five
hours a week 75 bucks what can you do
with those hours and what is that
seventy-five bucks worth to you I know
that there are plenty of people out I
used to do this when I was just
graduating high school I'd moved down to
Florida with my mom for a little bit I
was literally put taking ABS out and
papers where people just needed
assistance with just some really basic
needs checking on a grandmother
something and I would just pick up hours
here and there I know there are people
out there who would be happy to go do
something for you
for an hour for fifteen bucks let alone
for five hours a week for 75 bucks but
I'm just throwing ideas out there I
can't really speak to your family or
your friends
schedules like I said I'm sure you get
someone out there who will help you but
even if you don't have a close relative
or friend that can help you you will be
able to find someone out there to assist
him to take some of this pressure off if
you if that's what you need you know
what I think Ryan I think we shall find
out at once she sits down and actually
starts scheduling all those things
she'll actually find that she has more
time than she thought her schedule might
still be pretty tight but she'll have
enough time to focus on those things
that are essential to her now Emily two
things I'd love to give you we have so
we talked about priorities here we have
a book called essential which is sitting
right now it's a book it's 150 essays
about living and intentional life and
one of the chapters in there is about
priorities there's 12 different chapters
on 12 different areas of living an
intentional life and then also we're
finally making it back to Olive Oyl you
know Ryan we haven't been in Ottawa
since 2014 that that long tour
what's Ottawa what's in Ottawa we're
going to be we're going to be back in
Ottawa this year right effects we're
doing we're doing six cities in Canada
and so Sean if you could reach out to
Emily give her the book version of
essential or if she wants the audiobook
version that's on audiobook now it's our
longest book actually and it's it's over
six hours on audiobook read by the very
talented Justin Maalik who it was just a
great narrator he did such an
outstanding job with it but I'd love to
give her a couple tickets as well to
that event so maybe she can bring her
husband get him on board a little bit
not by trying to change him or
proselytize to him but just showing him
a different perspective on living more
intentionally well we'll see you at the
lessons now tour Emily all right our
next question is from West Chester Ohio
represent Ricky we we used to actually I
lived in West Chester for a little bit
Ryan lived over in Mason Ohio for a
while and we both managed retail stores
and in that neck of woods you're right
there in between Cincinnati and Dayton
what's your question Ricky
I discussed my mom and a friend of mine
the idea of minimalism and they looked
at me the same pitch they gave me B I
don't want to get rid of my stuff and
the just-in-case pitch and I wanted to
know how would you pitch minimalism to
those people so Ryan how do you pitch
minimalism the people Ricky why are you
pitching minimalism it's the worst way
to get someone to uh to take on this
philosophy the first thing I wrote down
I wrote down two words he said I wrote
well I wrote his question doubt how
would you pitch minimalism and I just
wrote down I wouldn't yeah yeah I mean
I'm sure that's not what he sure he's
not going to his friends and family and
no I mean he might be and I maybe we get
a lot of people come to our events and
stuff in their life I've been trying to
to convince my spouse or my family or my
friends to get rid of their stuff and
you remember the guy that brought his
daughter in I don't want to say what
city cuz I don't want to like even come
close to calling this guy out cuz he was
a very nice guy but he brought his
daughter let's just say I was in Regina
Saskatchewan I was not there okay but oh
he happens on a tour stop we absolutely
have um let's say was in Reykjavik
Iceland where we've never done a tour
stop no we haven't
no but uh he brought his daughter in and
he was like I need you guys to explain
to my daughter why it was great that I
threw away all her stuff you remember
that yeah I do that and and so my
response to those people when they're
asking like how do I convince someone
else to get other stuff is why do you
want other people to get rid of their
stuff it's such a strange thing to me
like why do i why would I want to like
when I first embrace minimalism Ryan I
didn't come to you and say hey man Ryan
I you know I care about you and because
I care about you so much I really wish
you'd get rid of 80% of your stuff but a
it's going to be such a turn-off but B
you're not gonna have any traction
because they're not going to understand
why and so instead of instead of trying
to tell people what the what is what the
what it is you're get rid of your stuff
you clothes your clothes or whatever
show them the why and for many P
what has to do with with how happy they
are right or how contented they are or
less anxious they are or the things are
able to focus on now and some for some
people it's like wow I really regain
control of my finances or I was less
tied to a career I didn't love so I was
able to change professions and now I do
something that's more in line with the
the path that I want to pursue you know
and and then the other people who are in
our lives as long as we're leading by
example
then often they will either come along
immediately or they'll eventually come
along I mean I can tell you that so we
had the in-laws in over the last weekend
because it was Ella's birthday and so we
of course we had a birthday party over
the weekend and invited her friends over
and then parents were came over and we
had had all that stuff but of course
Becks
my partner her family was over there so
so her mom and dad were there and quite
often they'll make funny little jokes
about boys sure does echo in here you
don't own a whole lot of stuff and you
know we'll just sort of laugh it off
because we know that like someone else's
that that that a statement like that
says a lot more about the person like
they own more stuff than me then it says
about me because I'm contented with that
it's not like I am meeting for something
it's not like I don't have enough stuff
for me or for Ella or for Rebecca
that would be a different predicament
you know growing up you and I we we had
too much clutter in one sense chaos
really is the type of of clutter but we
didn't have enough money we didn't have
enough security and we didn't we didn't
have enough in other areas and so I can
look myself in the mirror and say yeah
we certainly have enough and so whenever
someone comes to judge me and Ricky I
know you don't mean to be mean to these
people in fact your intentions are great
here you want to help them what you've
done is you've experienced minimalism
and you're like I am I'm all the way in
how do I get other people all the way in
we have to realise that these people are
in a different place from where you are
maybe you had an inciting incident like
I did you know with with my mother dying
and my marriage ended that that
shifted my focus maybe you had something
else that shifted your focus and maybe
they're not ready to hear that message
yet or maybe they're ready to hear a
different message about living more
intentionally they need to identify what
the benefits are and so the only way
that I can pitch minimalism to someone
else
you and I were doing a podcast interview
yesterday Ryan with some folks over a
Live Nation and the question I asked her
was how might your life be better with
less and instantly she started rattling
off a bunch of things things that I
wouldn't have thought of personally
first thing she was talking about was
well I hit my calls it would be a lot
less cluttered okay that's great
that wasn't the first thing I thought of
or maybe you'd take less time for me to
clean my house or you know what maybe
I'd have less debt if I owned less these
are all the benefits that people want to
want to uncover for themselves and it
last but not least Ricki I will tell you
that people mirror so the best way to to
preach minimalism to pitch minimalism is
to show not to tell over the weekend we
after the birthday party we actually we
was no different it was the day after
the birthday party with Ellis she just
turned four this this weekend I know you
did he took all the presents that they
got her and instead of telling them that
you don't want the presents you show
them you didn't want to by throwing them
in the trash while they were looking at
you and then I set it on fire and then
Backson I did the normal minimis chant
that we do we want left we want left we
started me to derail what you were
saying but here's the funny thing about
that so I will get derailed for a second
but you know we do a great job of
setting expectations backs and I write
on the invitations we put no gifts
please in fact I asked tell what she
wanted for her fourth birthday and you
know what she told me
the pineapple no I got her a pineapple
for a third birthday I figure she's
grown out of pineapples by now no I
asked her what do you want this is about
you know two two weeks before birthday I
said what do you really want for your
birthday and I didn't know what she
would say I was just interested to hear
what she had to say so the reason that I
like so much is
she's my little experiment and
minimalism for kids and so I said what
you want for your birthday and you know
she said she said Henry and chocolate
now Henry is her best friend he was born
a day before her so we had to go to his
birthday party last weekend as well but
so she the only thing she wanted for her
birthday really liked the things that
stood out most weren't all the trinkets
and gifts and all these other things
that that we think the kids are going to
give value from here I'll buy you this
large expensive toy no she wanted Henry
and a chocolate cupcake that's
interesting man well it's interesting
she didn't ask for any toys but then I'm
thinking to myself you guys don't have
cable television no so if you watch TV
it's you know I don't think you got do
you have a TV no and so but use your
laptop or whatever it may be but what
point is is like that's actually really
good signifier on the the entertainment
that you will that you and Becks allow
Ella to take in she watches a lot of
Peppa Pig and it's a Peppa Pig is this
in fact I noticed I don't know if I
talked about this on the podcast before
but I noticed that she will sometimes
speak with a British accent now when I
say a lot of Peppa Pig maybe an hour or
so a week and that's a lot for us
because we don't we don't know she's not
sitting in front of the glowing box
watching commercial after commercial
that isn't dr. nanny her saying you need
to have this right crazy toy to be happy
look how happy these kids are you'll be
this happy if you have this toy well you
know you need to insert ads into these
things too right and so here's a little
pro tip for anyone who has kids what
would I've learned so so the kids will
understand ads because it's just an
interruption should be mid Peppa Pig and
they have a mid-roll ad that just pops
up for you whatever toy or thing and
first thing she says this oh like she
starts panicking because like all of a
sudden her the thing she was in the
middle of she was engrossed and
interrupts is interrupted and we try to
watch these short episodes she watches
one she knows she watches one and she's
done but I pay more now for YouTube has
this version called YouTube red oh I saw
this familiar
okay yeah and so this is not an
advertisement for an ad-free platform
but uh I I found value in that because I
pay it's like ten bucks a month so it's
not cheap but it removes all the ads
from you but you think of all the pain
it causes with the ads like not only is
program getting interrupted but then the
next time you ask her what do you want
yeah she might have this thing embedded
in her brain that ya micromachine this
whole thing yes back in 1985 anyway my
whole point to Ricki is people people
mirror what you do and so the best way
to to pitch minimalism is to show
minimalism here Ryan when you came to me
you said why the hell are you so happy
it's because I was that's the only way I
had the pitch minimalism was to show
that my demeanor had changed I was less
stressed
I was calmer and it was affecting all
the other areas of my life my
relationships were incrementally
improving each day in each week and I've
noticed this is especially pronounced in
our kids right and so the story I was
getting to is right after we we had
dinner how we were getting Ellen to the
car she's little booster seat in the
back seat and I was putting her in there
and it was a bit warm I was nice and
sunny outside I was put her in there and
she almost said she just looks at me she
goes Jesus it's hot in here and she
won't know where she got that from she
said it would be exempt of pay what a
bad examiner I can't do a British accent
but I can only imagine how tough ELISA
actually so so the thing that's most
pronounced with a low with the Peppa Pig
thing is when she she says box of
chocolates
she says chocolate just like this
actually when it's box of chocolate and
and so yeah that's how you know we need
to start watching Peppa Pig for a while
but anyway she's actually since she said
Jesus it's warm in here but she said it
was the same exact cadence that her mom
would use I mean Jesus was was
italicized verbally you know and and
there was no comma in the sentence it
was just exactly how our mom would say
it who's me
your mom she was marrying her mom and
guess what we are just big kids we do
the same thing as adults we mirror and
so if we see something outstanding we
see someone changing their behavior we
tend to mirror that we surround
ourselves with people with bad habits
we're going to mirror that as well yeah
Ricky I would I would just encourage you
to yeah a live by example B look for
moments where maybe your relatives are
asking for your help um like when I went
to Josh and asked him hey what's going
on with you why the hell are you so
happy that was an open door for him to
be like well let me tell you about what
I've been doing or you know maybe your
parents or your family comes in like oh
wow like I've noticed that you haven't
had to work as much and here you must
have less debt oh yeah let me tell you
how I did that but you know going to
your relatives and trying to tell them
about the just-in-case rule it's not
it's not going to help because that's
going to put them on the defense now uh
he asked the question which I'm sure a
lot and I hear this all time I can never
be a minimalist because X and at the end
of the day when people say that I
usually will just respond with them and
say well not with that attitude and it
kind of lightens it it makes it a joke a
little bit but has to be someone who
could take a joke yeah but but you know
it's this I guess it still does open a
door um like Ricky I guess with the with
the very specific thing you said of I
can never be a minimalist because I want
to get rid of my stuff um I would just
say you know minimalism is not about
just getting rid of yourself in fact
it's about hanging on to the things in
your life that are most important I
remember Josh and I we were doing a
periscope is that stole thing I think so
yeah and while just call a live stream
yeah and someone they commented hey you
guys you guys you guys are kind of silly
your minimalists but you haven't really
gotten rid of anything important and
Josh was like yeah you're right I
haven't gotten rid of anything important
I've got rid of all the unimportant
things in my life yeah so I mean there
are certainly doors open with even
comments like that but certainly you
know Josh and I don't have them
catch for you Ricky I'm sorry yeah it
wasn't like you said you just echo that
point and maybe just put a bow on it
really quickly
it isn't about getting rid of everything
that's not minimalism that that is
deprivation and and so when someone says
I could never be a minimalist because I
don't to get rid of all my stuff you
just simply say well I didn't get rid of
all my stuff either I kept everything
that was important to me and I got all
the excess stuff out of the way and
sometimes that will open the door for
conversation other times it won't but I
don't think we need to spin our wheels
trying to convince other people to get
rid of their stuff there are many people
who will follow who will see the
benefits once you express the benefits
once you show them the benefits through
through your own actions to things for
you Ricky
one is Ryan and I we wrote about well we
wrote about the the whole well the whole
journey of going from the suit-and-tie
corporate guys to becoming minimalist it
was like a five year period of time and
a book call it everything that remains
it's my favorite thing that we've ever
written it's available as book books of
Shana tickets in him is a book version
the eBook version or it's now on audio
book on audible as well it gets into him
one of those I would definitely
appreciate that I met a couple this
weekend I was we were we were out during
Henry's birthday party and we were at
this like extremes that we took
four-year-olds to a brewery for a
birthday party that's his name is Ulla
Montana that's such a Missoula thing
they have I can't believe four year olds
can drink in this day yeah as long as
they card him right there at the door I
said he just turned four today fine no
but if they like these kid friendly
brewery is the wrong word right because
it's yes they serve alcohol there but
anyway it was and I don't drink so it
didn't really matter but it was this
kid's birthday party but anyway I met I
met this couple who was from st. Louis
and they had both met while reading they
were both in a coffee shop
they were both at the same time reading
everything that remains and they bonded
over the fact that like Oh like I've had
some tragedies tragedies happen in my
life recently
and the gals like I've had some
tragedies happen recently too and it
helped them find some common ground and
so hopefully that book will help you
find some common ground not just with me
and Ryan and the paths we took but it
will help you find common ground with
other people as well because it's not
about living exactly like other people
it's about finding some common ground
some things that we can greet agree on
usually those things are our values even
if you have different preferences from
some people if you have different
beliefs from some people that's okay
also we are going to be actually this
month
Ryan we're going to be back in
Cincinnati so Ricki I'd love to give you
a ticket or two I tell you it's the so
you and I were just in Minneapolis not
long ago we are so ago and Rebecca her
whole family is from st. Paul area and
they came out to our event and it was
like they clearly knew we were the
minimalists and they had even read some
stuff that we'd done and seen her
documentary and all this other stuff and
and of course Beck's is one of our best
cheerleaders for sure she she is down
for the calls but her family never like
completely got it right they didn't
connect all the dots and then they saw
the whole family came out and so us live
and it's always give a talk and record
the live podcast we also had Patrick
grown there at the Minneapolis event and
they were like oh I finally get it like
I now I understand this whole minimalism
thing and that's really what we hope to
do with some of these live events is if
these different these different vehicles
haven't resonated with everyone in your
life before whether it's a documentary
or one of our books sometimes it takes
that live event it's sort of this
immersion experience in fact we often
see that half of the people in the crowd
are people who were dragged there by a
friend or a family member right and
there they're going into a willingly
obviously they're not literally dragged
there but throughout the event you start
to see these expressions change it's
almost as if these light bulbs are going
off over their head and so hopefully
Ricki you can maybe bring someone with
you who's a bit skeptical and but it
still has an open mind you don't want to
bring a closed minded person to
something like this but someone who
sceptical and we can walk you through
sort of our journeys and we'll record a
live podcast to answer people's
questions as well and I can really tell
you that that's the first time that they
got it and all of a sudden like her
whole family was in the front row there
was like eight or nine of them she's a
big family and one by one the light
bulbs were turning on above their heads
and it was it was just really
encouraging to see that because yes
someone might read a book someone might
see a TEDx talk or whatever but
sometimes it takes that live immersion
experience so hopefully we'll we're good
to see a Ricky we'll give you a hug so
you can transfer that onto someone else
as well I think the biggest takeaway
from this whole thing is that if you buy
everything that remains in you're single
you will find your soul mate guarantee
you not guaranteed I mean Ryan you and I
have both read everything remains and we
have we have soul mates
how amazing is that coincidence yep find
your soul mate not guaranteed see store
for details all right our next question
is from Giovanni in Minneapolis I was
wondering what's the best way to
approach an intentional lifestyle
including minimizing items without
offending my family my mom and I are
like best friends but the men and I
decide to like make a donation bag or
get rid of items that aren't adding
value to my life my mom tends to think
that I'm almost losing value for money I
know it's because everything my parents
have bought for me has always been
high-quality and items that have truly
made me happy but as I grow and change
those things that added value to my life
previously don't really add value
anymore what is a more beneficial way to
sit my mom down and find a happy balance
between is allowing myself to be
independent and make my own decisions
and not making my mom feel like I'm
exhausting endless amounts of money I
want her to know that I love her and
respect her and so incredibly grateful
for all that her and my father has been
able to provide for me because I get it
I grew up incredibly privileged but for
me things and sheer quantity of those
things
doesn't really make me happy anymore
right you know what I would like to see
here I would love to see Giovanni
if she could sit down with her mom and
just play this podcast back not the part
where you and I ramble on and give her
an answer because hopefully we'll be
able to articulate an answer but
Giovanni just play your question back to
her yeah it's a great question you
articulated that so well stead of asking
the minimalists ask your mom this
question how can I show you that I still
love you that I still appreciate all the
things you gave me but unfortunately
some of those things don't continue to
add value to my life how can I show you
that I still appreciate those things
it's such a high quality question I
found that in my life when we start
asking higher quality questions we get
higher quality answers you you want
better answers ask better questions and
you're asking great questions here and I
generally don't say that you're not
going to hear someone answer ask me a
question and say that's a great question
but here's the thing you are actually
asking some great questions here I mean
I can give you some some advice besides
play your voicemail back but I think
that's going to help you more than
anything because what you're talking
about here is how do I communicate
effectively with my mother and and one
of the best ways to communicate is
listen to her so listen to some of her
concerns how do you the only way you're
going to understand how she feels and
why she gets offended or maybe she
doesn't actually get offended and you're
projecting that offense onto her because
here's the thing being offended actually
says more about the person who is
offended than it does about the person
then the person who's committing the
offense yeah and and and so I and it
doesn't mean that you're not offending
her and by the way you don't get to
determine whether or not your mother is
offended you can do your best to align
your actions with your values but let me
ask you this what are your values and
are your actions aligned with those
values and are you sure they are and if
so then you can feel really good about
the decisions and and your behaviors and
you can feel good about letting go of
the stuff because it's true
the things that are had in value to your
life today the things your mom got you
and she got him for you because she
wanted you to be happy and she wanted
you to feel
good and maybe they did make you feel
good in the moment maybe they did serve
a purpose in the moment but ella ella
just turned 4 and she got her new bike
for her birthday usual don't get
physical gifts for birthday but it was
an expensive bike and so we had some
other people chip in on it
I went over Ryan's I was sleeping and
got 200 bucks out of his wallet I'm so
happy I could contribute no it was it
was an expensive bike a bike it was like
$400 but L was really really thin she
weighs less than 40 pounds and she's
she's 4 years old she's super tall super
thin and this bike I wish I had the name
of it we'll put a link to it in the show
notes she's tried to ride other bikes
before like with training wheels and all
this other stuff and and this bike is
the first bike she got on with in half
an hour it was riding the bike no
training wheels no assistance just
riding down the street I haven't seen
her in four days sue did they make an
adult version of that I know right
well Ryan I didn't learn to ride a bike
until I was 37 wait a minute I'm 35
right now by the way Ella [ __ ] you not
Ryan l oh he's already rides a bike
better than I do in one day she she
rides a bike better but I did better
than I do but um we got her eh where was
I going with this we we got her a bike
on her birthday and man I totally lost
my train of thought and he reeled you it
was worth it for the joke I think no you
know I mean while you're trying to
rethink that Josh Giovani what I would
say and because I recommended this other
like mentoring clients that I've had who
have had this same exact situation and
what I recommended is when you are
getting rid of something that someone
else has got you and you feel really
sure that they're going to be offended
by you getting rid of it there is no
harm and going to that person and saying
hey thank you for this gift that you
gave me a year or five years ago
whatever it may be it's really added a
lot of value over that time but now it's
not really doing its job anymore and I
was going to try and find someone else
could get more value from it would you
would you get value from this item would
you
give this back to you I know that maybe
it was worth a lot of money
would you like to try and sell it on
Craigslist I just didn't want to offend
you by just getting rid of this without
going to you first and asking and that
approach has worked a lot and you know
what sometimes you know the people will
laugh and they'll be like no that was
nobody you were saying that I gave you
it's yours to decide what to do with
rich javonni that's what I would tell
you I mean if someone gives you a gift
yeah what if you--if you got her a gift
for example yeah if I got you a gift
give on a first off it would be to make
you happy it would be to add value to
your life if that gift was not making
you happy if it was not adding value if
it was doing the obverse if it was
actually giving you anxiety holding on
to it
well how selfish of it would would it be
for me to ask you to hold on to that on
him just because I gave it to you if it
was me personally javonni I would be
happier if you got rid of the gift I got
you if that's what truly made you happy
and the people who love you especially
your best friend they absolutely want
you to be happy they absolutely love you
so I'm sure that they would be willing
to support you in some way but you know
if that best friend is going to be angry
about the monetary value behind it then
you might want to go to them and ask
them if they want to try and get the
money back out of it but but hanging on
to it just to make that other person
happy is actually doing that person a
disservice yeah and I think sometimes
those are difficult conversations of
course but so I find the way that is
best to to handle those difficult
conversations is try to set expectations
weigh an event that doesn't always work
so again back to Ella's birthday this
weekend we we had the birthday party we
put no gifts on the invitation but of
course some people showed up with gifts
right because that's the obligation
people feel obligated to give a gift or
maybe they just weren't paying attention
they didn't see it whatever and we had
to have some conversations with some
folks this weekend like we don't need
that particular good or service you got
for Ella so I don't call me run out on
these foot massage jabs here but did you
actually you had that conversation after
they gifted it
yes well yeah now here's the thing it's
actually an easier conversation before
they gift it in fact of course now I'm
not
I'm talking about the day before they
gift it where they've already had their
mind made up when they've already bought
the thing yeah yeah like we need to
start talking about Ella's fifth
birthday right now like hey let's start
planning on this if we're not going to
need anything but you know what she
really does she really loves chocolate
and Henry apparently and so I or if it
is something we need like a bike like
we're gonna bust and 400 bucks on a bike
because she's actually gonna be able to
ride it and she's going to be able to
use this bike for several years to come
but that was my initial point that I
lost track on getting back to here that
bike now that she's four years old
eventually she's going to grow out if
she gets immense value from right now
it's it's her favorite physical item
right now no doubt about it we were just
on it last night while her mom was
cooking dinner we were like running up
and down the street was raining and
she's riding the bike through the rain I
mean this girl is riding the bike like
she's been riding it for years and it's
been you know less than a week and and
so there will be come a time though
where that particular bike for whatever
reason she outgrows it literally out
grows it it's not going to add value
anymore or it's going to add less value
over time and eventually will come to a
point where she's outgrown it and it
won't add any more value at all how
silly would it be for us to just well
we'll stick it in the garage and hold on
to that because Ella really used to like
it no that might cost a lot of money
yeah alright and it did right yeah
that's a lot of money and it may even
still be worth some money that I can get
out of it by then it may be so used and
worn down that it's worth virtually
nothing and and either way it's a sunk
cost ray
maybe I can make some money back on the
back end but it's silly for me to keep
holding on to that thing because she's
outgrown it now we as adults we outgrow
things all the time figuratively most of
the time and so many of the things that
you're talking about here Giovani they
are things that you've outgrown for
whatever reason maybe you like them at
one point maybe you love them at one
point but you've outgrown it and so it's
okay to let go and I think the last
thing I'll tell you here is you don't
want to preach any of this right and so
it's not about like well I'm getting rid
of everything because I'm better than
other people that's obviously not true
and I
that's not what you're trying to but it
can often come off that way and come off
as smug or as elitist and that's why
Ryan and I try really hard to not go
around and and tell people here's what
you need to do we show people what we're
going to do and so with your mom instead
of telling her what you're doing and why
you're doing it I mean part of that is
important to have those difficult
conversations it's much more important
as we said the last call or it's watch
I'm important too to show so show your
mom how your life is better and and also
show her how your life is not a judgment
or referendum on her life or any of your
other friends lives it's not you're not
trying to say everyone else needs to do
this say I'm doing this for me
and don't just say it show them that
you're doing it because if you are truly
happier you're less anxious you're
living a freer life then it's going to
be easier to show that than it is to
simply tell them those things man I have
gotten rid of like tens of thousands of
dollars worth of stuff so am I sold some
I donated that's all those
diamond-encrusted change you used to
have write all those Figaro's really
cause the thing that goes on the Figaro
a Jesus piece yeah that's it no it's
someone that I recycled and I'm just
thinking to myself I'm like if I would
have held on to all that stuff I
wouldn't have tens of thousands of
dollars I would just had tens of
thousands of dollars worth of stuff in a
storage unit or or I'd need a bigger
place and then I would just I would
actually be losing money hanging onto
that stuff yeah we don't think about
those extra costs man like the that the
ten thousand dollars worth of stuff
that's the price tag right but that's
not the value of the thing right the
price of the thing is not the value of
the thing this is a lightning round
that's what I would tell you to tweet
right now boom maybe we could still put
that in as a minimal maximum Shawn for
the lightning round
before we move on Giovani we talked a
little bit about values on your question
I'd love to send you a copy of our book
called minimalism live a meaningful life
it's our shortest book so we will either
send you the book the e-book or it's now
on audible as a two-and-a-half-hour
audiobook
and I uncovered the five higher-order
values what I would call the
foundational values in our lives and
wrote about those in that book once we
got the excess stuff out of the way we
really started focusing on these
foundational values and built a more
meaningful life on those values so we'll
send you a copy of that book I hope you
find value in it Ryan we should price in
her a time machine and a couple tickets
to the Minneapolis event stole the words
right out of my mouth all right Joe we'd
love to hear what you have to say so if
you have a comment or a tip about family
including any advice for any of our
callers today then leave us a voicemail
at four zero six two one nine seven
eight three nine you can also email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
comm we will air our favorite comments
and tips on a future episode all right
all right let's move on to our hashtag
ask the minimalists lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media we are on twitter and instagram
and facebook at the minimalists during
our lightning round this is where Ryan
and I do our best to answer each
question which is a short shareable less
than 140 character response we also put
the text to these minimal Maxim's in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you'd
like what a Patrick run say in
Minneapolis here's like I listened to
your podcast in your lightning rounds
they're not very pithy answer we try to
get there right right well I was
thinking if we actually did this where
it was question pithy answer you know
your pithy answer I put the answer next
question you know rinse repeat that
would actually be kind of be boring I
think yeah we I think we tried that once
the first time we did the lightning
round thing where it was just the the
tweetable answers we got to expound a
little bit yeah I think you do and
what's nice is you you expound and then
you wrap it up into this tiny little
package that is tweetable or face book
able or one of the other platforms right
Instagram Abul yeah I don't know about
you kids in these social medias all
right well let's let's move on to these
questions we got I don't know if you
know but I delete on my facebook
you can say I just prefer talking to my
friends and family in person and shot
how'd he know someone deleted their
Facebook account don't worry they'll
tell you all right a first question is
from initials P V how do you present
your minimalism to your extended family
well my short answer to this one is
actions speak louder than pontification
and you know I don't now let me point if
again for a minute yeah
my effect I was gonna say I don't think
I need to offend on that one that much
because that's really what we've talked
about here what showing instead of
telling right and so we can pontificate
till we are blue in the face but think
about pontification like this you say we
were in Grand Rapids recently which by
the way is one of the most underrated
cities in all of the United States I
getting better every time we visited it
was like it's getting better and that's
so good well the food options more
coffee options we were the bus a few
times are there they have this free bus
that goes from the downtown to the west
side and I mean it's just it's it's a
really great town anyway we were there
and we went to this coffee shop actually
it was a grocery store and on the corner
caddy corner from the the grocery store
there was one of those guys with the
like literally standing on a soapbox
would they make like an old megaphone
just yelling at people as they drove by
but about they're all going to hell well
the angelus wonder what his conversion
rate is yeah right exactly it's zero and
and I think that's that's the important
thing to remember when when we feel like
we're preachy or pontificating just
think about that guy with the megaphone
who's who's sort of schizophrenic Lee
yelling at traffic with with the
megaphone and just be really careful
right rather I'd rather show people the
life that I'm living through my actions
so yeah actions speak louder than
pontification I've got to pick the
answers first off I'm going to said the
same thing that we were tellin Ricky in
his question stop pitching minimalism
mmm all right well next one is is uh no
matter how one lives a meaningful life
showing always works better than telling
so this is a little very
wonder what you were saying Josh but I
could not agree more like there is no
there is no way to go when someone comes
into like hi I meet them for the first
time hi my name is you know so-and-so
what's your name I don't say my name is
Ryan I'm one of the minimalists or
especially when they asked me that
question what do you do I don't say I am
a minimalist yeah I mean I'll tell them
like I snowboard I'd like a look at
Montana what the heck is there not to do
I snowboard I like to float down the
river I like the long board I like the
mountain bike what do you what do you
really love doing yeah um and people
will flat out sometimes be like no no
like how do you make money and I'll just
start with I don't even start the
minimalist thing I'll just say oh you
know I came up with a documentary last
year and you know I've also written a
few books and the documentary was kind
of based off of that and that'll open
the door like if they want to sometimes
people will just take that because like
they've got their answer yeah they know
how to compare themselves to me on the
socio-economic ladder they've satisfied
they're crazy but yes exactly
but then sometimes it and most times
people will say oh what's that
documentary about oh what's called
minimalism a documentary about the
important things
oh really oh I've heard of that or I
think I've heard of minimalism and then
and then I will I might you know dive
into it a little bit deeper but I can
tell you right now there are people who
like I would just give them very short
answers because I don't want to be
preaching yeah and I will just yeah
minimalism the documentary about the
important things and sometimes it stops
there well it lasts me what's it about
and I will say it's about 79 minutes
it's genius I'm going to borrow that I
do this and in with our book what's your
book about
that's awesome all right our next
question is from David David once - no
gosh what's the best changes to make if
you've got a child on the way I had to
think a lot about this because I didn't
expect to become a parent and so I
didn't necessarily have a child on the
web because when I met Beck's Ella was
one and I dove in headfirst and treat
Ella as if she is my own child but I
could tell you the thing that I've
learned most so this is my short answer
it's this lower your expectations
raise your standards love that man I
that sentence or that statement makes me
think of our approach with the
documentary how we had no expectation on
tour in 2014 we didn't have the
expectation of oh we're going to hit
this many film festivals we're going to
have it on Netflix it's going to be you
know the number one independent
documentary for opening weekend in 2016
yeah what year are we in was that time
machine no but uh but yeah it's like we
started with very high standards right
we knew that Matt D Avella had high
standards himself so we were totally
willing to let him come on the road film
a bunch of stuff we we got you know the
first cut of the of the documentary back
before the music was even scored for it
mm-hmm and we just continued to raise
our standards from there yeah and Matt
did the same exact thing expired media
they did the same exact thing without
without having expectations right if
those would have been our expectations
it all it takes is one bad expectation
to all of a sudden spiral into failure
yeah dude if we had if we had a an
expectation of we're going to make you
know ten million dollars off of this
don't be disappointed forever because
it's never going to right because we
never would have met that one
expectation and all the other good
things out of it we would be like yeah
that's good but we didn't hit that one
goal that we laid out for ourselves
right and and so that's the other thing
to keep in mind when I say expectations
that really does have to do with the
goals and that's why I try to live a
goal free life I still have high
standards and that has a lot more to do
with with my habits and the quality of
work and also being able to enjoy the
work that you're doing and for me I
don't have I don't have a high threshold
actually yeah I don't have the capacity
for having fun like a lot of people I'm
a planner so I'm constantly playing ah
she's allergic my son I am I take
medication for it no I I'm constantly
planning for the future and it's harder
for me to be in the moment and so I find
that whenever I get outside of the
moment
I have to be I have to be grateful for
justjust there's a song let's do this
weekend it's an old song from the 90's
and anyway one of the little hip-hop
artists no no it's like and I know who
you live that old nineties hip-hop I
want to say KC Kahuna is the name of
this like it's like an atmospheric sort
of vandals in the Pandora Beck's and I
listen to it in the mornings we have
coffee but it's on these Pandora yeah I
totally use Pandora because that it I
have a cigarettes the only thing I
listen to it I'm like it's like calming
beautiful morning music for me anyway I
listen to that and there's this this is
line in there it says don't think about
all the things you feel just be glad to
be here and man that that lyric is so
profound to me I just be glad to be here
and and I don't do an outstanding job
with that not yet but I every time that
I know that I'm feeling overwhelmed or
stressed in the moment especially we're
out on tour Ryan like it's it's such a
great privilege to be there in front of
you a thousand people some nights or 500
people whatever it may be and I need to
step back and just say that line is I
don't I don't think about all the things
you feel I don't over think about all
the stresses like all the things that
might go wrong all your expectations
just be glad to be here and your we get
out there we give our best that's the
high standards thing and afterwards we
have this great opportunity I mean there
will be times where it's like oh it's
late man we just finished the event and
it's 10:30 at night and now we have to
go hug 400 people after this and I'm
like what a privilege is that right and
all I have to do is reframe it a little
bit and realize that man this is this is
the best place to be yeah it's also in
my pit the answer would be when one
lives on authentic life they needn't
change a thing and what I mean by that
is David what what kind of parent do you
want to be are you being that person now
because I know that it's too often that
people have realized to be guilty this
it wasn't
it's a little bit different because you
know I didn't tell myself when I had
kids I would make these major changes
which a lot of people do like whether
it's drinking a lot going out a lot
sleeping around whatever it may be they
are they tell themselves oh when I have
kids I'll change I should tell myself
all when I'm 30 I'll change and you know
what that's such a bad marker I would
just encourage you to ask yourself look
in the mirror like what kind of parent
do you want to be what kind of parent
does does your partner want to be
what are weird expectation to write
because when I'm 30 I'll change or what
about that arbitrary number right that
it's what about that is going to make me
you know what it wasn't it never worked
I remember what I couldn't mind when I
graduated high school when I'm 25
I'll change when I'm 26 okay when I get
that next promotion I'll change and it's
it's you got to change now yes so um
live an authentic authentic life David
and you won't have to change your thing
our last question is from Larry I've
been the poster boy for consumption I
thought I saw him on a poster somewhere
when he was a boy now I embrace
minimalism but my family now thinks I'm
a hypocrite when I get upset with
clutter help mm man what do you say Josh
I've got nothing for you Larry no I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so I am NOT a religious person
personally in fact Ryan and I have
different religious beliefs but I do
think I try to find wisdom from from
different books and one of those books
actually so so Rob Bell has a book
actually is going to be at our LA event
this month and he just came out with a
new book that I'm in the middle of right
now it's called what is the Bible and he
does such an amazing job sort of
breaking down the Bible in a way that
you would have never
he breaks him the Bible as a progressive
book even though it seems so antiquated
to a lot of people now it was definitely
like progressive at the time right but
he shows you why like specifically what
about what about it was progressive and
even the things yeah the things that are
progressive today won't be progressive a
thousand years from now
in years from now and and so I mean
progressive in the political sense I
mean I mean enabling progress right and
and so I have a quote from from the
Bible although I reworked it a bit
is this from Matthew or Luke I don't
know I think it's Matthew yeah it's why
do you look at the clutter in your
brother's room but fail to notice the
clutter in your own yeah so I mean I
think that's the thing that that I was I
was saying earlier with with Ricky's
question Ryan is you know why do you
want other people to get rid of their
stuff and when Larry says but now my
family thinks I'm a hypocrite when I get
upset with clutter and that that's them
judging you I'm not saying you're a
hypocrite right but but maybe don't get
upset with their clutter right just just
look at the the speck in your own eye
and so the plank in theirs which is the
the believe it or not this isn't the
original passage but yeah don't don't
look at the don't look at their clutter
be more concerned with your own yeah I
mean I just had to [ __ ] come come into
my my brain no uh I was just thinking
like what if like what if um like I got
I have friends who are like really in
shape like six-pack
you know like ripped in shape I am not
that type of healthy I guess like I feel
healthy I feel good but I don't have
like the vanity muscles but could you I
couldn't imagine could you imagine Josh
if you had friends like that and they
were always looking at you and going you
got some loved animals
now what's wrong with you uh you could
have a six-pack if you just you know
minimize your diet
I mean if someone was constantly riding
you about how you looked I mean this is
a you know obviously a much different
situation that's not that Demaryius
you're talking about genetics you're not
talking like if one yeah if you were 400
pounds you and I would have an
intervention and I was 400 pounds then I
would expect because you're my best
friend you care about me and if I was
overweight if I was fat a point of like
heart disease diabetes yeah or just or
even to the point where it doesn't allow
me to live an optimal life high blood
yeah apps
you care about me enough that you would
at least talk to me now you're not going
to be like hey man look at those love
handles and it's the same thing here
it's like hey look at your clutter yeah
like you would never you would never fat
shame anyone I would never fat shame
anyone I certainly wouldn't hang out
with anyone who fat shame people right
and the same thing goes for clutter
shaming yes there is no reason to
clutter shame anyone yeah well I'll tell
you this though sometimes putting [ __ ]
being ashamed yourself can be helpful
I'm not saying to shame someone else but
but I can tell you that there was a time
when I weighed 80 pounds more than I
weigh now and part of the reason that I
lost the way it wasn't just that I was
unhealthy but I was a bit ashamed that I
didn't not the fat but like that I just
didn't have control I was overeating and
I was ashamed of my lack of control and
so I think yeah if you're going to
instill shame in anyone it's in our in
yourself for the things that you want to
change a healthy amount of shame can can
go a long way yeah I guess my short
answer would be this Larry judging
others never helps accepting and
appreciating others warts and all is the
best way to help others move forward so
what that really means is if you want
the people around you to have less
clutter then support them as much as you
can like as long as they're not harming
you I mean if they come into your room
with oh okay we're going to need your
room to store all this stuff you know
that that might be crossing the line
except if it's their house and they own
the house and you're living in it
I mean it is kind of you know it's their
decision on what to do with that room
you can certainly speak up but
ultimately what I'm getting at is is
that you you really really need to stop
judging and you know go with what Josh
said instead of worrying about all the
things that are bothering you right
there in that moment what that clutter
just appreciate being here appreciate
having the life that you have in the
journey you've taken that is where
you're going to find the most enjoyment
that's we're going to find the most
fulfillment yeah man all right well
let's move on to our added value portion
of the shows where we each recommend
something or in my case things some
things but we've got things
and bang are the boardgame things no I
don't know maybe they'll be going to
recommendations well anyway we were
going to recommend some things that have
added value to our lives recently this
is sort of an audible but Ella's bike I
mean that is I've never seen a kid I
said this is not a I didn't it wasn't a
commercial that I saw for this bike but
we were looking for a bike for Ella
because I knew she was if she's really
thin and she can't lift a really heavy
bike right get her a bike it's thirty or
forty pounds it's gonna be really hard
for her to ride that thing in the state
balance and that's why kids often need
training wheels she circumvented the
whole training wheel process altogether
she's never had to have training wheels
at all because of this bike we got her
and so I saw this video of this kid who
was similar in build to Ella he's
probably a little bit bigger than her
and he was trying to learn how to ride a
bike and this is like just a pet some
parents who like a testimonial video
yeah yeah in fact it was just that these
parents who were like cheering their kid
on to ride this bike he couldn't ride
the bike they got a like they kept
trying and he just was too heavy for him
and so he was having trouble and then
troubled two training wheels and then
all of a sudden they got him this other
bike this light bike that we got for
Ella and I'll send a link to Sean and
you can put it in the show notes Sean I
don't remember the name of the bike off
tell my head it's not like a huffy or
something where I remember the brand
right away it's a specific bite in fact
it doesn't have a chain the chain is to
keep it lighter is like this Oh like a
rubber belt type yeah Rob like do we see
like a timing belt kind of thing in a
car but it's it's right there on the
bike anyway within a few minutes I saw
this kid on this video with very little
editing all of a sudden riding this bike
and I'm like oh man this is the bike for
Ella and then I go research it I'm like
oh my god it's like $400 and so we're
like hey maybe some people will pitch in
and we'll get it as as a birthday gift
and so that's what we ended up getting
her and so if any of you have kids that
is that are trying to learn to ride a
bike I think that might help you out and
the next thing is it's also a thing that
I want to recommend I'm staring at it
right now because looking like a pewter
screen right it's this camera protector
and again
another brand of this but Shawn I'll
send you links we can put it in the show
notes I used to put like a piece of tape
over my camera on the computer after
what was it called that movie Snowden
maybe yeah yeah the Snowden movie yeah
and and because I I didn't won't say it
freaked me out but man I do some stuff
in front of my computer but I don't want
anyone else oh man yeah I gave mariah's
always paranoid about that you gave me
one I yeah I bought one for the whole
team basically yeah I gave I handed it
on Mariah she's definitely using it I
you know it's funny the one of the
biggest lines that stood out and that
movie to me is when he talked to his
girlfriend and she's like well if you
don't have anything to hide like what's
the problem he's like well that is that
the whole question is the problem yeah I
agree with that well I want to agree
with it but I still don't understand it
because like I wrote let me explain it
then yeah cuz I still come from that
viewpoint where it's like if you want
you look at my phone here here's my I'll
tell you my password you can look at all
the stuff on my phone if you want to let
watch a recording of my life like I
would totally like I had nothing to hide
so alright because it's not true you do
things that are illegal on certain and
and so the problem is we have so you
have 70,000 pages of walls whatever they
are and so we all do something that is
what is the average American commits how
many felonies yeah I think it's two
felonies a week insane yeah and and part
of that has to do with antiquated laws
we're not these aren't selling these
that most people are going to get
prosecuted for you know like in some
states sodomy is still illegal and and
you're like we'll wait a minute like in
there they're a bunch of laws like that
we wear it there there are laws that are
on the books that the no sane person who
can prosecute prosecute for except
here's the problem when you have a
tyranny you know a tyrannical dictator
take over a country and I'm not saying
that's what's happening now but no
you're saying that it's terminus yeah
and its terminus you you get a you know
a kim jeong-hoon figure where they have
absolute access hmm and they will ruin
your life because they have absolute
access to it so that anything they want
to use against you they can and so yeah
Mason they may not not doing something
bad
you perceive but if someone else
perceives it to be bad then all it just
becomes this very slippery slope very
quickly and so yeah I may not be doing
anything bad in my eyes but I know that
not everyone's going to agree with my
with my points of view and so that way
of thinking is does end up being the
problem because all we're just one
tyrant away from from some sort of weird
martial law and and division and so I'd
like to keep that to the minimal anyway
food but the camera protected I have on
a computer it's great because it slides
back and forth and it's aesthetically
beautiful it looks like it's part of the
the computer that I own and so it looks
like in fact I bet you this would come
built-in within three or four years
every computer will have this little
sliding mechanism it's like a kind of
like a little sticker but it slides back
and forth it adheres to the computer but
if I want to use the camera I slide it
over to the right I use the camera to do
a Skype session or whatever and then I
slide it back and it's good to go three
other things real quick I have an album
a book and a movie a new album from the
hip hop R&B artist LA it's called aura -
he is the artist from North Dakota who
lives in Atlanta but his name is LA but
it's not spelled LA like the city it's
spelled elh a and the L for our foreign
listeners that's elh hey Ryan and I were
we were in Canada
we're in canada yeah it's almost because
sometimes we'll we try not to
personalize books because want people to
get rid of them afterward for signing
books yeah we don't really personalize
look so someone was like hey my friend
couldn't be here they're sick you can
you sign this - Lizzie I'm like yeah how
do you spell that
Elle oh I I said I'm like Z I started
writing ze d so like wait I got a
houseful Lizzie said like that what is
that yeah so anyway yeah la his album is
called aura you can find it where a good
digital music SoundCloud iTunes Spotify
etc a book I want to recommend I just
saw the movie the circle and it was an
okay movie I love Tom Hanks as an actor
but the movie was not as good as the
book I know you've heard me say that
before never heard anyone say that yeah
first time I've ever heard anyone say
that about any movie that was how could
it be down book I feel good as the yeah
anyway
anyway the book is outstanding it Dave
Eggers did a phenomenal job to me it's a
masterpiece
I love the book it's the book I wish I
looked at any novel that's ever been
written in our lifetime it's the book I
wish I would have written either that or
freedom by Jonathan Franzen but but the
circle it takes place in a not too
distant future and it approaches both
sides of our technological advances so
you've got you've got the Luddites
perspective and you totally identify
with the person who wants to completely
Ashu technology altogether and live off
the grid and then you also agree with
the person who is like Edward Snowden's
girlfriend or whoever your time but I
was like what's the big deal
technology's just helping us is doing
nothing but aiding humanity and you see
that perspective as well and it's really
our job to figure out where do we fall
in between those two perspectives and it
was a phenomenal book the movie didn't
do it justice so check out the book
instead and then I have something that's
the opposite I just saw the movie called
the dinner with Richard Gere and I read
the book a few years ago but I forgot
that I read the novel and this is in the
what the movie is considerably different
from the book it takes place in America
whereas the book takes place in Holland
I believe anyway it is a decent book but
an outstanding movie and it really makes
you think about consequences and also
how we treat the people in our lives and
it takes place over the course of one
evening and it's called the dinner I
would encourage you to check it out if
it's still in theaters or you might be
able to find it online streaming
somewhere all right Ryan anything adding
value to your life recently um I'm a
little late to the game here but I saw
guardians of the galaxy - totally worth
it yeah I'm not like a Marvel fan so
anybody who is a marvel fan out there
they're like I can't get in the so lame
Wonder Woman's already out anyway which
I'll go see next Wednesday with my
Marvel fan friend uh the other thing I
think I've recommended this maybe on a
previous podcast not going to recommend
it again there's this tea the brand is
Yogi Y o GI and it's called soothing
Carmel bed
time so it's it's that particular that
particular tea that they make the
soothing Carmel bedtime dude it is like
it is unbelievable I don't know what
they put in it like I had to like look
at the ingredients so like I'd even I
mean it's look some herbal stuff yeah
yeah I've heard someone else recommend
this as well Tim Ferriss has recommended
it oh okay sure it was also check it out
because Beck's
uses like the sleepy time tea at night
yeah they didn't which it up you can get
in taste good yeah taste that's it -
like it tastes freakin amazing and it
within 20 minutes of me drinking like
I'm starting to get that tired feeling
um yeah it's you can get it anywhere at
your major grocery stores I don't think
like a 7-eleven you're gonna have it but
uh those of you who shop exclusively at
7-eleven let 7-eleven credit card I got
the point sauna yeah um and I did
mention that that game things earlier I
wasn't planning on recommending this but
there is a board game well it's more of
a it's like a card game anyway it's
called things and essentially it's kind
of an adult like you don't want to like
it gets adult really quickly so you pull
a card from this deck and it'll say
something like things you wouldn't want
to hear in a library uh-huh and say you
Shawn and I are playing uh-huh we each
have a slip of paper we write down you
know things we want to win here a
library an earthquake or like you know
you try to throw people off like I don't
want to hear whatever like insert
ridiculous thing that you wouldn't want
to hear inside of a library yeah it
becomes sexual and you and they really
come with like it becomes poop and farts
like pretty quickly yeah yeah um but but
yeah it's a great game it's the more
people you have the more fun it is and
the whole idea is you have to guess who
said what aha so it's really cool for
people that you know you've known for a
long time to play with how many people
do you use about usually like eight I
feel like how well you know someone and
then people you don't know you get to
know them a little bit better
uh-huh um but yeah I don't like cards
against humanity' know what it is it's
like cards against humanity' and apples
the app
like combine unless you ever played
apples that I've heard about it but
anyway yeah it's it is a very fun game
and I just thought it was ironic to
recommend things on the podcast alright
so let's move on the right here right
now so we talked about what's going on
in the lives of the minimalists a few
things Ryan and I have a side project
called minimalism life you can just go
to WWE know some life we have a bunch of
free wallpapers over there minimalism
dot life I'm sorry yeah it wasn't that
life yes ww minimalism life life is the
what's a top-level domain PDL for for
those of you in the know I like the
Internet
and so fun anyway
minimalism of life is a side project we
have you can follow it on social media
as well Instagram is the best place to
follow minimalism life because coral
over at minimally Simo who we partnered
up with he handles that that account and
we just closed a bunch of really
beautiful architecture design
photography it's a well curated feed and
also we just put out volume two we put
out a quarterly volume with a bunch of
different writing about minimalism so
what we try to do at minimalism life is
we combine minimalist travel minimalist
design and architecture and then
minimalist well-being so Ryan and I the
minimalist we are the well-being side of
things and then we curate a bunch of
other stuff as well so the second volume
came out everything we have over there
is free except for the quarterly volumes
I think there are five bucks a quarter
like twenty bucks a year and the cool
thing is you get access to the back
catalogue as well so you get access to
the first volume and the second volume
if you're interested in that if you
don't want to support it you just want
to check out the free stuff you can do
that as well minimalism Dot life Ryan
and I are also on the road it's called
the less is a now tour we've been to
twelve cities which you check my math
here Ryan we're doing 40 cities this
year I mean 28 more to go
still a math podcast by the way let me
get my abacus out you are the abacus oh
yeah
so here the cities we're headed to we're
going to be this month we're actually
headed to seven cities this month we go
out for a wave at a time three or four
cities at a time first it's California
we're going to be in San Diego that one
just sold out we'll be at the House of
Blues there but I got some cool opener
we have opener Nicole ray is going to
start railing a Cole
is going to be there and she's opening
up for us and then we have a really
great guest the Lewis house will be our
our guest at that event and Los Angeles
tout after that we're going to have Rob
Bell there and run River North is going
to be the band who opens up the show I'm
so excited about that and that one sold
out did I say that yeah okay San
Francisco is not sold out but there are
maybe a dozen or so tickets left so if
you're in San Francisco or the Bay Area
get your tickets now while you can that
one will be sold out really soon and
then we're heading over to the Midwest
we're going to be Indianapolis
Cincinnati Columbus and Cleveland right
on one of our favorite musicians like
our probably our favorite shared
musician like if we have we put our top
10 list of shared musicians he will rank
highest on the top 10 favorite favorites
list and Rubel is going to be at our
Indianapolis event opening that one up
that one is going to be so much fun but
then we're going to be back in Ohio
Cincinnati Columbus Cleveland tickets
are available for all four of those
events and then after that we're taking
a little bit of a break about two months
this summer but then we're headed up to
Canada we've got six stops Toronto
Ottawa Montreal Vancouver Calgary and
Edmonton before heading back to the
States
Philadelphia Manhattan Brooklyn headed
over the mountains after that Salt Lake
City Denver Phoenix down to our first
well actually Canada's international but
then we're headed internationally again
to Texas waited and now we're headed to
Austin Dallas and Houston three great
cities there will have some good
turnouts tickets available in all of
those places and then we're ending the
year in Nashville Washington DC atlanta
Tampa Detroit and Milwaukee we're going
to have a bunch of special guests not at
every stop but peppered throughout the
tour you can find all those dates cities
theaters over at les is now calm what
about overseas you come into Africa and
Asia and Australia and other places that
begin with a
and the answer is yes if all goes well
in North America we'd love to take the
less is now tour to your country so if
you decide up for our email newsletter
over at the minimalist comm you will be
the first to hear about all of our new
events as they're announced Ryan and I
also are trying to build a podcast
studio as I mentioned at the top of the
show we need your help we need to get to
2,000 patrons we're a quarter of the way
there already but we really need your
help guys here's the way I can really
say this I hate continuing to ask for
this because we don't want to do
advertisements on this podcast but we do
need your help each episode so we get
about I think it's 3 plus million
downloads a month so it's been as high
as 6 on sort of peak month but that
means most of our episodes average about
a million downloads per episode
give or take right and if we got you
know half of a percent of our audience
to just donate a buck or two per episode
we could really create a sustainable
media company for lack of a better term
now I don't mean news media I mean it
allows us to create meaningful things
whether it's great video creations or
whether it is video essays or new
documentaries or miniseries or our own
TV show that we can get out there to
folks we really need your help just a
buck or two an episode over at
patreon.com slash The Mentalist
minimalists that will help us out a lot
you can find a link to that in the show
notes as well by the way if you're
donating two dollars or more per episode
you're going to be part of our special
monthly live stream our first one is
going to be at the end of June and we're
going to do a monthly live stream will
also record that video live stream as a
private podcast just for those patreon
supporters so if you want a private
podcast where you can interact with us
face-to-face or Mike - Mike sort of
thing you want to interact with us on
the live stream you'll be able to do
that and we'll record that of the
podcast and send that out to all of our
our patrons as well also you if you
can't afford to support us monetarily I
totally understand that no pressure
we're glad you find value in the message
but you can leave us a review on Apple
podcasts that
those reviews help us spread our message
to more people
I haven't tallied up the final results
from last month yet Ryan but we we saved
several lives last month thank you to
all of you it really does mean a lot we
did we did a $10 donation for every
reviewer we received on Apple podcast
last month and we started the month off
with just over 2,300 and we're over
3,000 reviews on Apple podcasts now and
we're really grateful for all of you who
decided to do that not only because it
helps get our message out in front of
more ears but also Ryan and I are
donating 10 bucks for each one of you
who took the time to leave a review and
so if you want to leave us a review we
always love 5-star reviews but we expect
you to be honest with your reviews as
well so you can leave whatever you want
we're grateful for whatever you leave
Ryan you got anything else yeah man I've
got some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners hey guys this is
Nikki from Mount Pleasant South Carolina
I just listened to your podcast called
media and I actually have an app
recommendation I do have an Android but
I'm pretty sure there's an iOS and
iPhone app out there that's similar
it's called app detox and I love it
because it allows you to restrict and
even block access to apps on your phone
so I personally use it for Facebook and
Instagram and I allow myself a 30-minute
time limit each day but at times
especially when I find myself getting
lost in the infinite scroll of the news
feeds I'll actually block access
completely so I think that it has added
a lot of values of my life and I think
can add value to a lot of other
listeners lives as well
my gosh and Ryan this is the light in
Rochester New York of the show just
wanted to leave a comment on the media
episodes you had a woman call in asking
about news sources and not a better
manager news I did this a while back and
did the research and basically easy to
put in the amount of research that you
want to get out of it
in causing your juice source that you're
getting from your - so what I did was I
wanted international phonetic vocal so I
did some research teaching tries to
narrow down new solids that would fit
those three criteria trusted to sources
not diet that was important to me
supplement that I also added an app
called countable and what it does that
uh alert you to any upcoming legislation
or garvin trend or tell vital important
- and a really good way of having
something keep you in touch with your
government and things that are important
plus the exhibit know what another nice
feature on p.m. also is you can as a
direct link for your representative but
your senator your your representative in
the house president and what you do is
you can usually boldly yes or no if you
approve the quick solution if it's not
something that currently on the House
and Senate you get to take action but
you can email your representative on on
a trend or tissue
so those things have really helped
minimize my new day and make it simpler
for me rather than checking you know a
million different latorte ready Club
with Twitter and I you cry 5 minute nice
Sue's outlet smart and accountable and
these notifications from those different
new salads really keep me up to date
and while it sounds like a lot it puts
the issue and that way I can get my
value out of it and then move on with my
day I don't have to worry that I'm
missing something or anything like that
hi this is Hudson from Toronto and I
have a tip for those listeners who love
to drive motorcycles owning a motorcycle
can be quite expensive with monthly
payments insurance costs fuel and
storage if you live anywhere it snows so
a few years ago I sold my bike and now
spend many of my weekends riding for
free every major motorcycle manufacturer
now has demo days where they will let
you test-drive new bikes for free it's
also a great way to meet new people and
explore places you might not otherwise
go if you live in a large enough city
you can even find one of these events
every week for the entire summer all you
need to bring is personal safety
equipment and you're all set
just visit your favorite motorcycle
company's website and they will have all
of the information you need enjoy
alright y'all that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also leave us a voice memo at
podcast at the minimalists comm and if
you leave here with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little singing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little singing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you were fine
without it
[Music]
every little singing that you got a hand
every little scene that you guys you
gotta reach for you gotta Greg oh I bet
that you'll be fine without so tear your
[Music]